Reggie Miller part of the TNT crew with
Kevin Harlan le Loup force Lakers Bucks
in Milwaukee 8:00 Eastern on TNT
good morning red a matchup doubleheader
we have this Thursday I am excited I've
been waiting for this for a few weeks
yes I wouldn't say we got the a game
though between the Lakers and the books
but no slouch having Houston and the
Clippers follow up so a fantastic
double-header how do you explain the
Bucks losing at home to a Dallas team
without Luka done chicken last night
well that's why you can never take
anyone for granted in this league I
think it was a miss sight a misstep and
oversight probably looking ahead at home
no Luca and having LeBron and Anthony
Davis and the Lakers on your mind you
took him from granite you thought at us
playing at home we would have enough to
beat them even without Luca and
porzingis who has struggled all season
has played well in spots but not great
found that 3-point stroke and yeah I
just think they overlooked them and it
happened McLovin is a hot take on the
Mavs
McLovin you ready to give it to Reggie
yes so watching last night the ball
moved a lot more and porzingis was
featured more without Luca dodge it's in
the game maybe he should handle the ball
West maybe his usage numbers should go
down to help everybody else this is why
you're probably in the back row next
time absolutely not that's one of the
craziest things I've ever heard McLovin
we have a stat that he's 10 and 2 when
he shoots less than 20 times and 7 and 6
when he shoots more than 20 times right
we are talking about one of the faces of
the NBA
over the next 10 years and the way the
game is played today you've got to have
a ball domina either point guard which
I'm considering Lou
years now since he plays point for them
and how he controls the game he controls
pace style she can shoot from deep
he sets everyone up on this team if you
took him off the ball
number one who's going to handle it for
the man Jerad Braaten
who I think Jalen Brunson Rick fronting
that down
he was great last night well Dave the
ball Dominique I just won a title Reggie
who's won the title with that formula
the harden style it hasn't happened you
have to pass the ball they pass it up
they pass the ball enough they do I
think the ball has to be in Lucas hand
it does but the warrior style is within
the Raptors last year you got to move
the ball around I this whole trend
towards a 101 is alarming me as a purist
as the basketball serious I can see that
but they do have a flow office it just
so happens the ball is in Lucas hands 80
to 90% of the time I like to know in his
hands I like the ball in his hands I
know that you can look at the numbers
there McLovin and think that they're a
better team when he doesn't shoot as
much but you can still have the ball in
his hands and you know so he can still
be ball dominant but they could still if
he shoots a little less they could be a
little better but I still want the ball
in his hands comparing daunted game to
harden because I know yes tons of threes
gets you line a million times these game
ball all the time
what's so what's not the same there
aren't they both in top three and
three-point attempts and foul shots I
don't think they have the same game and
I think in my opinion I think Dantas is
a more willing passer
I think Harden wants to score the
basketball that's his primary thing and
then when they triple team them that's
when he throws an alley-oop to capela or
finds those guys in the corner I think
Don should look to get other got people
involved we're talking to Reggie Miller
the Hall of Famer he's got Bucks Lakers
coming up on Thursday night I was wonder
about this last night and that is how
many teams is it NBA Finals or bust
Lakers Clippers bucks anybody else
Billy see I don't think expecting I know
Philly has talent but it feels like we
cooled on them
whereas Milwaukee has been great picked
up where they left off i I don't know I
just figured there were three teams if
the Rockets don't make the finals Mike
D'Antoni may lose his job but I don't
know if it's NBA Finals are bust for any
other teams but the Lakers Clippers in
Bucks I don't think the Rockets will get
to the NBA Finals I don't think they're
gonna get through either the LA team but
the to LA teams Milwaukee silly who look
no walkie has you know getting to the
Conference Finals having the best record
being up to O versus Toronto last season
in the conference finals and then losing
definitely championship or bust
and I think Philly after the
disappointing you know being around the
rim shot by Kawhi Leonard and MV trying
I think it's championship or bust I
think they're on the clock right now
with those two guys have been Simmons
and Joelle and bead so those were
probably my championship or bust type
teams yeah I mean you know I start to
look at you know where the Lakers are
and and this was brought up to me by
somebody in the NBA they're like do you
think that Kawhi is being selfish or
selfless and do you think LeBron is
being selfish or selfless so LeBron
doesn't believe in load management he
wants to play
where is Kawhi needs it believes in load
management so he's ready for the
playoffs so could you see where somebody
is being selfish or selfless in this
situation I can make a case for both
their head okay um and that's the way I
answered it yeah I can make a case for
both because being in LeBron situation
he is not wrong and I agree with him
whatever since if I'm healthy if I'm 80%
I want to play because he's right about
there could be
it's heard of me Tennessee the parents
are saved up money to come see me I'm
going to play on the flipside what's
bigger a championship going deep in the
playoffs being ready for your team so I
see Chloe's point that's why you and I
about a month and a half ago we were
talking about who's better at LeBron
collide I kept going to quiet quiet
schools on that because you can't you've
got to be able to play every every game
the kawaii' is not gonna play every game
and I'm glad you came around just like I
did with Anthony Davis top five you you
can't you you've got to be able to play
under duress when you're tired
back-to-back so that's just that's what
it is but on the flip side I understand
what he's coming from I want to be ready
come April 15th
once the playoffs get going when there's
no back to backs and remember he played
the most minutes of any player during
the playoffs last year collided why
people are gonna go back to he only
played 60 games during the regular
season so I can I see their point did
you see the story with dion Waiters that
he was suspended by the heat he called
in sick and then he reportedly posted a
picture of himself on a boat and what's
the worst excuse he ever heard from
somebody missing a game we're missing
practice you not to name any names i'm
picasa my head I can't is that that
really takes the cake right there that
is that's so embarrassing and what a
blacker respect for the Heat
organization for clothes small straw for
those guys the Heat have turned the
corner I thought and have been playing
fantastic and to do something like this
is such a slap in the face and you know
this Heat team I don't know if they can
win the East but they're they're really
sneaky good they're fun to watch you
name it they jack up a bunch of threes
Tylar hero who i told you was gonna be
in the Rookie of the Year conversation
which he is Duncan Robinson from
Michigan who can flat-out shoot the
basketball and then you've got a bona
fide closer in Jimmy Butler you got
Kendrick Nunn who's also a rookie
Spoelstra has opened up the offense to
kind of let these guys you know expand
it a little bit and run so there are fun
team to watch that's why it's a slap in
the face who wouldn't want to play that
style of basketball I mean so for dion
Waiters to do something like that it is
such a slap in the face to the rest of
his teammates you know whatever beef you
have with management with Pat Riley and
that's that should be on them but don't
disrespect the game and disrespect your
fellow teammate by doing acts like this
it's such a it's a slap in the face I
don't know if you heard Shaq and Charles
Barkley be critical of Joelle embiid and
B did say that he considered a
constructive criticism even though he
puts up unbelievable numbers I always
feel like he can do more and maybe
that's not fair to him but I I do expect
it feels like he could be great every
single night I think he's he's
sporadically great he should be
averaging 25 and 15 on a bad night but
what what's the what's what's why isn't
it happening because I think he lets the
defense off the hook way too much I
think he settles for threes when he
doesn't have to and he is so gifted and
talented with his footwork and it's back
to the basket he could get anywhere he
won in the pain and between his pump
fakes and his footwork on bad nights
he should be 28 and 16 on good nights
wouldn't they called him out like vs
Boston and he went for 38 and I believe
it was 30 that should be a nightly thing
because the way they are playing Big Ben
today where you can't really body and
hold and armbar he's too big and too
talented and then when they do do that
because he can
you up I'm not telling him to shoot
threes but his 18 to 20 foot jump shot
is pretty pure so he can have them on he
can have most defenses on a yo-yo and I
think he just lets them off the hook by
at times playing very passive so I under
I understand the call out by the by the
two big fellas because they're right he
should be the best player in the game
with his skill set better than everybody
you think he's got that much talent that
he could be the best thing he's not
going to be like Yanis or Luka because
those guys can handle the basketball go
coast to coast and do a host of things
get triple doubles which I think he can
he's a great passer but in terms of see
the reason why I think this holds so
close to Shaq Shaq was so dominant as a
sinner I mean there there was no
question during his era he was the best
player and I think Shaq sees a lot of
joelle in him that he needs to put guys
down Shaq put guys down I mean guys you
talked about the blue flu guys would
call in sick not to play again Shaq and
that's why I think it holds close to
Shaq because he sees the potential in
Joelle you got the kids ready for
Christmas there we are we're getting
close we're getting all we were getting
alpha on the Shelf look up on the Shelf
by the way was alpha myself around when
you were no it wasn't around when I was
around no we didn't have yeah
EML we're doing self on the shelf and
I'm trying to find which I do I do know
they have like the the game the toy that
I love the most when I was growing up
do you remember Rock'em Sock'em robots
yeah oh my god
that was I mean I love the sound of it
when you when you oh my gosh
money is ten-year-old Reggie's like we
named I believe the blue one was
Muhammad Ali
we made the red one either kid Norton or
George Foreman and that's how we played
we would play that hours upon hours
right Rock'em Sock'em robots
fast-forward to this summer we're on
vacation in Hawaii and we walk into Dave
& Buster's and I don't know the last
time you've been into Dave & Buster's
which is unbelie-- has every video game
imaginable they had a life-sized the
size of my son Rock'em Sock'em robots
you talking about a 50 year old plus man
go die they're gone to heaven it was
unbelievable so yeah Rock'em Sock'em
robot I'm trying to find that for my
mini-me because I want to get them
hooked I think that we have a Rock'em
Sock'em robot but my man cave is so big
that we've lost track of where the
Rock'em Sock'em robots are because we
all grew up with Rock'em Sock'em robot
what else did you grow up with like
favorite Christmas toy let me see see we
were more of a game family so well we
got together it was more like clue
monopoly the arguments the fight that's
what it was all about for us see I love
risk because I just look like taken over
her country taken over there the East
the Far East the Middle East Europe play
Yahtzee and three of a kind four of a
kind
that's why I can't go to Vegas now but
what was your first real pair of
basketball shoes they were top ten
adidas do you remember the top ten
adidas mm three stripes on the side top
ten Adidas I had a poly I had the
conference Ollie I got them converse
allstar high tops is what I had the
powder blue North Carolina blue
so you're not tired older than I am like
we couldn't have afforded adidas neither
could we were on the government budget
we lived at the commissary so we should
shop at the Air Force Base all the time
so that in Kmart that's where we got
most of our our kicks from did you have
and then you had a basketball obviously
you got that we had a basketball Pop's
made a in the backyard he put on all the
cement himself and that's it was I don't
know maybe ten by twelve and which got
expanded because we started to shoot you
shoot until we wore out that ten by
twelve and then it went to like 15 by 15
and we had the hoop yeah so is that
who's still there it's still there in
the backyard of Riverside California no
kidding
I know and this is other games that we
would this is crazy how we think of
things it was called cork ball so we
would get old corks we would put
athletic tape around it and that would
be your ball and we would get old broom
handles break it off sod off and that
would be your bat and that's how I
learned Tibet that's why I had great
hand-eye coordination because you're
trying to hit the cork which was the
ball and you would flick it under your
middle finger and your thumb that's how
you held it and you flicked it when I
come in
to New York into the studio I'll show
you how to play and you could play 2 1 2
or 101 and that's what we would do for
hours Cheryl and I Tammy and I my
brothers that's how I learned how to
play baseball was playing cork ball but
I I'm curious though at that time like
how important was basketball to you like
that did your parents or it wasn't like
if I said you could have played because
your brother played baseball were you
any good at baseball that was my first
love yeah I want to be the next to Rod
Carew yeah baseball basketball was the
second I didn't really get into
basketball until maybe my sophomore year
and then interesting.i Kareem
abdul-jabbar told me that he always
wanted to play first but he wanted to
play first base for the Brooklyn
Jers like that was his goal and then he
said I kept growing and you know same
story i was 5-9 when i entered high
school and it was all about baseball I
loved the way cleats sounded when you
walked on dirt I mean I was like
obsessed Rod Carew rock growing hitter
ever and that was it so when I got to
high school the coach was like you're
gonna pitch I'm like pitch pitch even in
the chapel Little League is different
from Pat pitching on a high school mouth
like I'm not gonna pitch she's like oh
you're gonna pitch I'm like well I'm
playing basketball thank you very much I
started to grow and Here I am talking to
Theodore yeah you know thirty years
later I think it worked out for you
I think it did too and I think so well I
would have been a picture if I could
have been like Jericho well wait a
minute
look at these NBA numbers here Red's
come on he's gonna work on Thursday
night though it'll be Lakers bucks at
8:00 Eastern on TNT with Kevin Harlan
and Allie LaForce does LeBron say
anything to you prior to the game so
we'll probably DAP up that's it that's
it and by the way I always secure on
Ronnie jr. being the fifth best LA after
you saw that performance in Ohio is he
the fifth best player in California he's
not starting yet but hey I'm the one
that said LeBron stays in the NBA until
brogni gets there you know what
[Music]
I think you're right have fun on
Thursday night in Milwaukee you're not
you're not staying in the haunted hotel
or did you believe in walk the halls no
I dunno okay okay it feels like one of
your teammates may have believed in that
probably mark Mark Jackson there too New
Yorkers are scared of everything
Thank You reg we'll be watching on
Thursday night happy holidays that's
Reggie Aloysius Miller for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]